I'll be traveling next month and don't want to miss my coffee in about time.
It gets to be a lot of stuff to travel with.
My thought is to add boiling water to the grounds at night and let it set overnight to
straight and use in the morning thoughts, tips, or tricks.
Okay, so, go back to the course, let me go on the course really quick, and see what
there.
Do I have it?
Maybe it's on this page, or I have a video there, it looks like that.
Okay, so this page, I'm going to share my screen with you real quick.
Okay, so this is the membership site, so on the membership site, this is the page entitled
Detoxification Details, I have to see if this is, oh, I guess it's not working.
So we get hit YouTube that takes down videos of ours literally every week, such a fight
with the world these days.
So, this, you already know how to do coffee animals, you're an expert at how to do coffee
animals.
I created an easy PC way to do coffee animals right here, this works really good if you're
out and about.
So this first step, prepare coffee is what you're asking about.
So literally, when you're out and when you're, when you're traveling, just go get some
organic coffee and make some coffee in the morning and let it cool or add a little bit of water
and do the easy peasy way where you're standing in the shower doing the coffee animal.
So just keep it really simple as I wrote here, just keep it really simple, don't stress,
you're doing a coffee animal, just stimulate your parasympathetics, if you're stressing
about doing a coffee animal, you're defeating the whole purpose of doing a coffee animal,
you're stimulating your sympathetic to try to stimulate your parasympathetics.
So just do it super easy.
If you'd have to go buy a cup of coffee at a coffee shop or if you have a coffee maker
at wherever you're traveling, just make some coffee, you know, it doesn't have to be done
the perfect way.
So just do it, just do it that way, that would the way I would do it and make your coffee
and then do a steady coffee in the shower just to make it easy on your traveling.